those are some lucky fans we've got a
close-up concert from Rick Springfield
whose new album just dropped today and
we've all sung along to Jessie's girl a
million times but when you hear Rick
explained the meaning behind his hits to
our Carly's deal well you might hear
them a little differently next time I'm
kind of known through the ages is this
kind of happy shiny guy but I was really
dark all my songs don't talk to
strangers are all like sexual paranoia
is all dark stuff rick has always been
brutally candid about his depression
even admitting to an attempt at suicide
as a team it's music a way of you know
overcoming that and pushing through that
it has really helped give a voice to my
oh give me a focus get my depression a
way to get the hell out of there also
helping Ricky deal with his darkness
Barbra his wife of 31 years there's a
couple of songs on the new record
there's one called Let Me In that I
wrote for her
she still inspires me been married a
long time we've been through a lot ups
and downs and one of the down moments
and I was the one saying let me in at 66
Rick still has that Rockstar swagger
with his new album rocket science and
he's constantly on tour what would you
say is the hardest part of being on the
road well I can tell you that right it's
not getting enough sleep I can sleep for
14 hours every night I love to sleep I
can't get off stage without playing
Jessie's Girl I know that you personally
ever get tired of playing or do you
still find something new every time you
perform it really honestly at running
out your prettiest kid for the uncles
and aunts to who and all but really is
all it is that's crazy I always thought
those four section upbeat songs I know
right
well he's gonna be on stage tomorrow
night rocking the I heart 80s party and
you can hear it live on I heart radio
stations and streaming on iHeartRadio
com